an American is among to NATO service
members killed in the latest Taliban
attack in the capital of Afghanistan the
car bomb in Kabul yesterday killed 12
people and wounded 42 others it's part
of a string of attacks launched by the
Taliban this week as the militant group
reportedly edges closer to a peace deal
with the u.s. Charlie d'Agata is in the
Afghan capital Charlie why is the
Taliban launching these attacks now
well good morning Anthony they're
launching these attacks now because
these peace negotiations are underway
and while they may be talking peace in
Doha here in Afghanistan they're still
waging war in the most brutal way now
take a look at this video from
yesterday's attack not far from the u.s.
embassy killing that u.s. servicemember
you mentioned and another NATO soldier
as well as at least 10 civilians near
the US Embassy sixteen US service
members have been killed in Afghanistan
this year
now as for that peace deal underway the
government here has been completely shut
out of talks between the u.s. and the
Taliban to underscore that President
Ashraf Ghani was shown a copy of the
draft but he wasn't allowed to keep it
now in a statement after the recent
attacks Ghani said peace with a group
that is still killing innocent people is
meaningless
Tony Charlie d'Agata in Afghanistan for
us Charlie thank you